معنا في الاستوديو المقرره الامميه لحقوق
الانسان في الاراضي الفلسطينيه السيده
فرانشيسكا البانيز اهلا بك معنا سيده
البانيز نبدا بتطورات الاخيره وتحديدا
تحذير جوتيريش من ان الهجوم على رفح سيؤدي
الى مفاقمه الازمه الانسانيه والى عواقبه
اقليميه كذلك هل هناك اي اصداء لهذا
التحضير شكرا لاستضافته انا افهم
وشاطر الامين العام قلقه وحرصه فيما يتعلق
بال خطر المزيد من المذابح في غزه واننا
نشد ذلك فعلا فهو شيء يحصل يوميا فعدد
المدنيين القتلى يزداد يوما بعد اخر
والعمليه الرياضيه الطيه تدل ان عدد زياده
عدد الناس الذين يحشرون في مناطق واراضي
اصغر
واصغر مساحه هذا يجعل من امكانيه زياده
عدد الوفيات كلما هناك ضربه جويه ضدهم ان
محكمه العدل الدوليه امرت اسرائيل بالتوقف
عن قتل المدنيين والتوقف عن تدمير المباني
المدنيه ولكنها
اسرائيل تتجاهل كل ذلك وتتجاهل قرار محكمه
العدل الدوليه وما طلبته من اجراءات مؤقته
هذا امر غير مقبول بالفعل بعد وقت وجيز من
قرار المحكمه هناك نسف لمربعات سكنيه
كامله قمص لمدنيين يعني لا نرى ان حده
القتل قد انخفضت كما كان يفترض او يتوقع
بل زادت حتى ما الذي يمكن القيام به في
هذا
الوضع لك هناك عده امور تدعو الى الصدمه
وقد حصلت بعد القرار التاريخي الذي اصدرته
المحكمه وان اول ذلك هو ان الدول الاعضاء
لم تطبق لحد الان و تنفذ اوامر المحكمه
اولهم اسرائيل
فالمحكمة منع الاباده الجماعيه لان
المحكمه ادركت وقالت ان هناك امكانيه
عاليه بان هناك عمليه اباده جماعيه والشيء
الصادم الاخر هو انه ليس فقط دول الاعضاء
لم تتخذ اجراءات لايقاف عمليه الاباده
الجماعيه بل اتخذ اجراءات ضد انر التي
هي التي هي الوكاله الوحيده التي يمكن
تقدم مساعدات انسانيه التي طلبتها وامرت
بها المحكمه اذا الامر غير منطقي في ظل كل
ما ذكرته الى اي حد هناك فعلا التزام دولي
بوقف معاناه المدنيين في
غزه هناك هناك امكانيه قويه للمجتمع
الدولي وان يقدر ان يوقف هذه المذابح وه
وقرار المحكمه يعني ان عليهم يتخذ اجراءات
ملموسه وهذا يعني حسب راي اولا من ناحيه
السياسيه وايضا اتخاذ اجراءات اقتصاديه
ولابد من تعليق العلاقات الاقتصاديه مع
اسرائيل بالتاكيد وفرض حضر الاسلحه عليهم
كما ان اسرائيل هي اول شريك او اوروبا هي
اكبر شريك اقتصادي لاسرائيل وبالتالي
عليهم ان يوقف تعاملهم التجاري مع اسرائيل
وكذلك على الدول الاخرى ان تفعل شيء ذاته
هذا الشيء وهناك ايضا لتحقيق
العداله بالانضمام الى اجراءات محكمه
العدل الدوليه وكما وهذا وهذه تقوم بها
الدول عربيه دول اوروبيه اذا هناك بعض دول
الجنوب تقوم بذلك وايضا لابد ان هناك
ولايه دوليه لمحكمه الجنايات الدوليه
لمحاسبه مرتكبي الجرائم هذا هو العداله
الان بدنا نرى مشاهد حتى من قبيل استهداف
قوافل انسانيه تابعه للامم المتحده يفترض
انها متجهه لمئات الالاف من الجوع
الفلسطينيين الذين يعيشون ظروفا انسانيه
صعبه
جدا مع العلم ان اسرائيل مطالبه ك سلطه
احتلال لديها التزامات تجاه هذا الشعب كيف
تراقبون هذه
المشاهد نعم طبعا
نراقب ان اسرائيل لم تحترم ابدا القانون
الدولي هل هل احترمت القانون الدولي لو
فعلت ذلك لما كنا هنا لنتحدث عن الاحتلال
غير القانوني وعن الفصل العنصري والنظام
الاستعماري والذي يرتكب جرائم اباده
جماعيه ضد فلسطين في غزه ويستمر في ذلك في
عمليه التطهير العرقي التي يقوم بها في
الضفه الغربيه وفي القدس الشرقيه لا ما
كنا نتح ذلك لو لا اسرائيل سمح لها ان
تنتهك القانون الدولي منذ عام
199 67 واي انها تفلت من العقاب وهذا ما
يجعل الاسرائيل اكثر امنا وسلاما بل هذا
الواقع لا يحصل ذلك بل ان هذا وضعهم في
فخ هذا الذي خلقوه بانفسهم اذا اذا اذا لم
يتوقف كل هذه الامور في هذا الوقت تتك
فيها اسرائيل باباده جماعيه فمتى
ستتوقف اذا هذه هذا التفكيك وهذا التاكل
للنظام الدولي بقدرته على حمايه الضحايا
من الاباده الجماعيه والفضاءات الاخرى
وتامين السلام سلام واستقل المنطقه لان كل
المنطقه الان على فوفه بركان نعم تحدثت عن
التحريض على الاونر و
وقطع المنح التي كانت تقدمها الدول لهذه
المنظمه المهمه جدا بالنسبه لملايين
اللاجئين الفلسطينيين والان هناك تهديد
بالتوجه الى رفح ما الكارثه التي تنتظرنا
الان في هذه المنطقه في ظل ما
ذكرته اعتقد ان الكارثه فعلا قد حصلت و
وقد قد لا ندرك ذلك بشكل كامل او ندرك
بشكل كامل تاثيرات هذه الكارثه لاولا لان
العيون الوحيده لان الشهود الوحيدين في
غزه
هم الموظفون الدوليون القلائل الموجودين
مازال هناك من الامم المتحده وغيرهم من
مكاله الامم المتحده ولكن الضحايا الذين
بقون على قيد الحياه من هذه الاال البشعه
هم الذين يمكنون من عرض
هذه الاباده الجماعيه على شاشات التلفزيون
هناك مجاعه لا سابقه لها ليس فقط في غزه
بل في اطراف اخرى من العالم اذا الناس
سيموتون سيموتون بسبب المجاعه و بسبب قله
او عدم توفر الادويه والعقاقير او الماء
الصالح للشرب اذا كلما تاخرت المساعدات
وكلما تاخر وقف اطلاق النار زاد عدد
القتلى
والوفيات وبالتالي ليس هناك اي طريقه اخرى
لانهاء كل هذا الا عن طريق التوصل ووقف
اطلاق نار ودخول فوري ل القوافل الانسانيه
لان ما يصل الى غزه
حاليا غير كافي اطلاقا ليس فقط الاونروا
تعرضت ل شيطنه وتحريض ولكن ايضا الامم
المتحده عموما منذ بدايه هذه الحرب بدء من
تصريحات السيد جوتيريش في بدايه الحرب الى
المساهمه التي قدمتها الامم المتحده في
دعوه جنوب افريقيا امام محكمه العدل
الدوليه كيف تتعامل الامم المتحده مع هذه
الاتهامات وهذا التحريض وكيف يؤثر على
جهودها لطالما كان هناك مستوى عالي جدا من
الحساسيه ازاء اسرائيل هذا امر تاريخي فم
جانب انا افهمه انه في جميع الاحوال ان
اسرائيل ينظر اليها على انها الدوله اسست
وخلقت نتيجه ظلم كبير جدا لكن هنا هناك
جانب اخر هذه
الروايه الظلم الذي ادى الى تاسيس دوله
اسرائيل وله معنى كبير للفلسطيني وتاثير
كبير على الفلسطينيين الان بدات تظهر
الامور لاول مره هناك الكثير مناقشات حول
ذلك المخصص لهذه المقابله شكرا لك كنت
معنا في الاستوديو المقرره الامميه لحقوق
الانسان في الاراضي الفلسطينيه فرانشيسكا
البانيز